it's been almost seven years since the
British band keen last made music
together was there anything you were
nervous about coming back as a band
god I was terrified I was just nervous
about playing the songs right for
drummer Richard Hughes bassist Jesse
Quinn songwriter Tim Rice Oxley and
frontman Thom Chaplin the reunions been
emotional you guys have known each other
almost as the beginning of time right
Chaplin and rice Oxley have been close
friends since childhood as a kid I just
remember thinking Tim was the aloof cool
older brother he could play Airwolf on
the piano there's a TV show yeah right
the big break for Keane came in 2003
when a small label agreed to release a
single they kind of said well we'll put
out a song see how it goes
right and that song was everybody's
changing everybody's changing would put
the band on the map in England I
remember that feeling being really
exhilarating Keens debut album hopes and
fears would sell nearly 6 million copies
behind the international smash somewhere
only we know the band's first four
albums all went to number one in the UK
but some critics mocked them for wearing
their hearts on their sleeves you guys
have often sort of made light of the
fact that you're sort of a middle class
band is that a pejorative in your view
you know inevitably people start sniping
at you you know it's that that's the
nature of any kind of success and then
you start getting into this habit of
like well we better put ourselves down
before someone else does even more
troublesome Chaplin began an ongoing
battle with drug addiction which in 2013
would contribute to the breakup of the
band eventually I knew is going to
completely ruin me because you know that
it really became my whole life
and at the same time I daughter was born
and no doubt what I would be dead if I
carried on doing I would have killed
myself with it because their toll it was
taking on me mentally and you knew that
oh yeah yeah
after Keynes split rice Oxley's marriage
fell apart in 2014 he was arrested for
drunk driving after steering his car off
a country road into a ditch left me in a
place eventually what I really needed to
you needed some help us buddies is going
through that part of what ultimately
brought you back together yes definitely
it's not always been rosy and perfect as
a friendship but it's always been a very
important one way the most important one
after two years of being out of touch in
2017 are now sober Chaplin reached out
to his old friend I hadn't realised just
how deep his pain had been about with
his marriage breaking down and how much
of a hole in peanin really and then once
I heard the songs you know he really
made sense
those songs make up cause and effect
Keynes
new album a reunion that's allowed the
band to see itself in a whole new light
it's great to have that opportunity to
to be able to do it again and see see
stuff from a different place and that
maybe you're not so bad yeah simply
self-deprecating or to to mean about
ourselves we give each other a look now
because you know you I think one of the
things about becoming happier is you
have to we have to learn to like
yourself it sounds like a small thing
but to break that habit and to actually
be really proud of what we've done and
what we are doing that's a big break